la musique militaire résonne dans le
centre de Kiev une cérémonie sobre et
émouvante devant la cathédrale
Sainte-Sophie
[Musique]
l'année dernière ce jour-là les premiers
missiles s'abattaient sur la ville pour
le président zellenski cette date
anniversaire du début de l'invasion et
l'occasion de clamer haut et fort que
l'Ukraine remportera la victoire cette
année il rend hommage aux soldats
je remercie tous ceux qui ont vécu ce
terrible moi de février et cette année
et qui donne à l'Ukraine l'invincibilité
gloire à tous ceux qui sont maintenant
au combat
une gerbe est déposée devant le mémorial
des soldats disparus les autorités ne
communiquent pas sur le nombre de morts
mais il y en aurait plus de 100 000 pour
la population cette journée du souvenir
est nécessaire beaucoup de familles sont
séparés la douleur et la tristesse ont
envahi leur quotidien mais les
Ukrainiens ont su rester unis
nous sommes ici aujourd'hui parce que
c'est un jour déterminant cela fait un
an depuis le début de la guerre
et j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas de
prochain anniversaire
je crois que cette année nous mettrons
fin à la guerre
l'opéra de Kiev était hier soir illuminé
aux couleurs de l'Ukraine et tôt ce
matin le président Zelenski partageait
sur les réseaux sociaux un premier
message
l'Ukraine a surpris le monde l'Ukraine a
inspiré le monde l'Ukraine a uni le
monde
alvif des faisceaux lumineux en hommage
à ceux qui sont tombés dans ce cimetière
les familles endeuillées espèrent la
victoire et la paix